we've tended unfortunately to see
addiction as either a sin or disease but
there's no other disease for which 80%
of the treatment is prayer confession
and meeting hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Maya Solomon she's an author and a
journalist and the author of the
excellent new book unbroken brain a
revolutionary new way of understanding
addiction Maya thanks for talking to us
thanks so much for having me okay so
it's a revolutionary new way of
understanding addiction talk a little
bit first about the old way what how do
we think about addiction
well we've tended unfortunately to see
addiction as either a sin or a disease
but there's no other disease for which
80% of the treatment is prayer
confession and meeting and there's no
other disease where if you have the
symptoms of it you can get sent to jail
so what actually goes wrong in addiction
is that you fall in love with a drug
instead of a person and that's a
learning problem like the way you learn
to be in love with somebody is very
different than the way that most of us
learn math although some people can fall
in love with math but if you are a
non-autistic or not obsessive person
that probably won't happen you will
probably remember your first love
much better than you remember whatever
you learned in first grade one of the
things that people always talk about now
we're increasingly because with the
disease model is the idea that the brain
is actually changed by drugs it rewires
the brain and it makes you do this
behavior how does that fall short of
explaining what's going on sure well
people never shoot up in front of the
police people plan very carefully to
ensure that they have a supply and that
doesn't look like they're not making
choices it's very similar to the way
people act when they're having an affair
they see ground they tell lies they do
things that they wouldn't otherwise do
in order to make sure they can be with
that person addiction basically rewires
your brain in the same way that love or
parenting does and I don't think that's
good obviously during an addiction but
it is not
breaking your brain it is not
progressive pathology what is the
implication for treatment and for
criminal policy well for criminal
policies really obvious if addictions
compulsive behavior despite negative
consequences negative consequences ain't
gonna fix it and we really need to set
policy that recognizes that for
treatment what I think really needs to
happen is we need evidence-based
treatment and AAA is absolutely a
wonderful self-help group and people
should be referred to it because social
support is very useful in recovery but I
don't want my tax dollars or my
insurance dollars going to pay a
thousand dollars a day for content that
you can get for free in a church
basement that also has this problematic
powerlessness and god stuff one of the
things that you deconstruct and this is
the idea of the addictive personality
why do we want to believe in an
addictive personality and I'm not saying
that there isn't something to that
because we clearly know people who are
compulsive about everything
the thing is that all people with
addiction are not that way and so what
I'm talking about more in in debunking
the addictive personality is the idea
that a person with addiction is a liar
is scummy is antisocial is basically a
bad person and while people with
antisocial personality disorder which is
basically the diagnosis of bad person
are over-represented among people with
addiction
that's only 18 percent of people with
addiction so 82 percent of us should not
be given that stereotype the other thing
here is that racist stereotypes play a
huge role in how we see drugs and every
major drug at various points was
identified with a marginal ethnic or
demographic group because it could be
blacks or Mexicans or Chinese or kids we
have with ecstasy or LSD what's going on
there and how do we get past that um I
think people do create identities around
the substances that they use and so then
the dominant culture can use that to
attack people but really we have to
confront the fact that racism is the
only reason the illegal drugs are
illegal and the legal drugs are legal
and
nobody could make a rational decision to
make tobacco legal marijuana illegal
that's all about racism in Colonia you
know are we growing up as a society and
our treatment of intoxicants because you
know there's certainly a lot of
Puritanism going on and about how like
you should never use any kind of drug
you should never be drunk or intoxicated
by the same type of way of places like
Washington State in Colorado and more
and more every American is taking
prescription drugs to kind of alter
their moods or energy levels are we
becoming more realistic about drugs or
are we still trapped in this kind of
weird bifurcation where this is good
drug that is bad drug um both they're
going on I do think we're getting better
the marijuana legalization stuff has
really opened up the dialogue that was
sort of stagnant for at least 20 years
and the opioid crisis has really also
made people start to think that you know
what we're doing isn't working the UN
this year has the goal of in ten years
having a world free of drug abuse not a
world free of drugs so well that's
pathetic it is progress and I think you
know we really are we're realizing that
people are wired differently and some of
us may need certain chemicals that we
don't have within us in order to
function that doesn't make us bad or
different or wrong the problem that
comes with drug use is when it kills you
or when you are using compulsively
despite negative consequences and it's
hurting your family and your work so we
need to focus more on addiction rather
than drugs and I think we're making
progress towards doing that I do think
that also once you legalize marijuana
and the world doesn't collapse you sort
of realize why is it any better to lock
up people for using heroin
I think people it's gonna take longer to
realize that selling may not be best
dealt with through criminalization but I
don't think anybody now even the people
who are like the severe drug warriors
can give a good reason for locking
somebody up for using we will leave it
there the book is unbroken brain by Maya
salivates it's a revolutionary new way
of understanding addiction Maya thanks
thanks so much for having me for reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie